[Music]
so when trying to play a note or record
a short dry and staccato as possible
there are a few things I think about it
helps to prepare for it by placing your
fingers on the keys before you play
sometimes I think it's even possible to
be depressing the keys slightly being
relaxed right before you play the chord
and at the tips of your finger is
relying more on the scooping sliding
Peck motion rather than up and down if
you're doing this up and down motion in
my opinion unless you're you know
lightning fast there's some waste and
movement by changing directions because
up and down you have to change from up
back going down to up whereas if you
rely on the sliding Scooby that's off
the case
so recently I told the young student of
mine to imagine that the key bed was
burning hot but only when you're
producing sound so with that in mind you
can actually just rest your hands on the
keys but the moment you play the keys is
going to be as short and quick and swift
as possible so sometimes you don't
really have the time to prepare for the
note and in those cases I think it's
really important to focus on being
relaxed but being precise when you're
playing so relaxed and precise I also
find that it helps to be listening out
for the space after the note when you're
trying to play something very dry a lot
of these things happen intuitively when
you know exactly what sound you want to
produce
[Music]